why was it important to you to
reassemble
kylos helmet and when you're crafting a
beat like that is there any concern
about undoing the decision he makes in
last Jedi no I think that part of it is
about his you know his commitment to the
the dark side you know he as you'll see
his becoming supreme leader and without
giving anything away
you know his sort of focus has been a
little bit you know more on practical
matters he's assumed you know that
position within the first order and so
this is a bit represents his sort of
recommit Excite to the Knights of Ren
and then you know because of a very
specific thing that he's about to go do
so it as you see in the story it's
there's a reason for it which it might
not be clear obviously at this moment -
we've been talking about with people
before about masks and that's such a
huge you know iconography of Star Wars
that you just that we took for granted
that we had to reimagine so what is it
about someone who hides himself you know
or presents the person to the world but
underneath is something completely
different and I think for the maybe
there's a moment in this one where
that's surprising that's so bad